alex ist sonst immer so lieb und
rücksichtsvoll und jetzt redet er die
ganze zeit nur von seiner eventagentur
die ergründen möchte mag ist das totale
gegenteil er macht einfach gar nichts
mehr
seitdem philipp hier wohnt ist er total
eifersüchtig so telefon für dich lass
uns gleich mal über lena reden konnte
doch gar nicht überleben größten das
telefon in der küche wo sonst
hallo vincent ist schon irgendwie
komisch eigentlich ist er ganz in
ordnung
na ja er ist sooo schlecht gelaunt und
freundlich ein bisschen ruppig der ist
ein kürbis wie ein buch entsteht ein
kürbis nicht kürbis so nennt man die
kellner eine kölsch knappen hier in der
region
die sind zwar ein bisschen ruppig aber
haben das herz am rechten fleck
du bist schon sehen im grunde ist
vincent ein guter kerl wirklich
sag mal erzähl mir dann noch mal von dem
typen der dich verfolgt hat was war denn
da genau
ach das war eigentlich ganz harmlos wenn
lutz und ich wir haben uns tausend mal
verabredet aber er ist nicht zu den
treffen aufgetaucht aber war jetzt nicht
gefährlich oder nein das nicht
er war nur sehr schüchtern naja gut
verstehen du bist hübsch das mädchen da
kann es einem schon mal die sprache
verschlagen
danke ich helfe dir
machst du den umzug wo soll denn
christus sicher dass die mutter nicht
doch mieter einziehen